rich how are you my friend what's up
buddy
um i'm in costa rica right now trying to
you know minimize impacts of great reset
i have um i have three guys in my
community that live there they moved
there in the last couple years for the
uh named benefit benefits that you're
fully aware of okay yeah fantastic so i
i started my search by going to hawaii
uh mexico most recently from brazil
and i have two
two young boys and i'm really trying to
you know find a find a spot where
i can i can raise them and have
decentralized food
uh number one and
i don't know this is
this is where i am right now okay so do
you agree do you disagree what i talked
about you know like what's your solution
because you mentioned something about
talking solutions in the private chat
i mean my solution is removing myself
from a tyrannical government um i almost
you know put the kibosh on coming back
to costa rica because
they are trying to vaccinate you know
children under 5.
since done away with it but
you know to me the solution is kind of
what you already touched on is being
more self-reliant um
and and part of the reason why i'm here
is because everybody grows their own
food
it's also a spot where if things do go
to [ __ ]
uh you know people in the us people in
canada are accustomed to
having everything
copacetic 100 of the time so
the power goes out there they're going
to respond differently than you know if
the power goes out here for example
and as far as decentralized currency
because i'm because i'm assuming that
there's
that known benefit in where you're at
right now like you see a case for that
in the future especially with like the
last caller wanted to argue that the us
is too big to fail the us dollar will
still be dominant you know blah blah
blah but i don't see that i see the u.s
failing i see the u.s dollar
um not real like the only reason why a
twenty dollar bill is worth twenty
dollars is because everybody agrees
right now that it's worth twenty dollars
so they exchange that value for it but
the value that it holds is diminishing
rapidly over time
and they're moving towards central bank
digital currencies which offer them full
monitoring of all transactions via the
blockchain
right
yeah i hold crypto i hold gold part of
the reason why i'm here is i i purchased
to have a international diversification
of my my funds and resources
um but
you know if you're a fan of brent
johnson in the dollar milkshake theory
then you know there's going to be a
evaluation spike in the dollar
and ultimately you know led by by a
collapse and so every currency every
fiat currency in the world goes to zero
and you have to take steps necessary in
order to protect yourself from that
when is that gonna happen who knows but
it's inevitable right yeah i see it
coming too
absolutely all right man
thanks for coming in but
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you